oh it's just you thank goodness listen
today we're going over some of the best
horror games you can play on Steam deck
but here are the conditions it has to
run well on deck and it has to be a good
fit for the handheld on the go form
factor
you'd best get in here too
this first game takes place in space
where no one can hear you scream dead
space is a survival horror game in which
you play as Isaac Clark an engineer
Center repair a ship's communication
system after it mysteriously goes
offline unfortunately for him that
repair job quickly turns into a battle
for survival when he finds the ship is a
floating human slaughterhouse I'd
definitely be looking for a new job and
a therapist once I escaped with the
remake of 2008's release right around
the corner January 27 2023 pending any
surprise delays fans and newcomers alike
might be eager to experience the
original series of games in preparation
if you fall into that category of Gamers
you'll be happy to know the Dead Space
games are functional on the steam deck
valve has the original game listed as
verified and during our own tests here
at Gamespot John Luke found that Dead
Space runs great on Deck the only issue
seems to be with the camera but the good
news is that this seems to be an issue
that affects the port of the game on all
PCS not just theme decks if you want to
fix this you'll need to put in a little
extra work unlike the original Dead
Space 2 has not been fully tested by
Valve and is considered playable during
John loose testing the game ran
flawlessly with no camera issues to
speak of so if we had the power to we'd
definitely slap a verified sticker on
this one ourselves Dead Space 3 is
listed as playable as well but we didn't
bother to test this one because well
it's Dead Space 3 but considering how
Dead Space 2 runs we're confident this
third and much less scary entry will
also be a great experience on Steam deck
this next game takes place on Earth an
earth that's in such bad shape space
might be a little more welcoming while
arguably not as scary as the Dead Space
series Dying Light 2 still has what it
takes to get your heart pumping
especially if you explore the game world
after sunset in the original Dying Light
you play as Kyle crane an undercover
agent determined to find Intel on the
deadly virus taking over the world dying
like two stay human takes place 15 years
after the events of that game but
civilization is still all types of
screwed up in it you play as Aiden
Caldwell a member of a group of
freelance Runners and you're on a quest
to find your sister Mia valve has both
games listed as verified and I can
confidently say that stay human on Steam
deck earns that title the game runs very
well when in low quality mode with
upscaling fsr2 turned on what makes
Dying Light 2 so good for the on the go
experience is the parkour is so
rewarding that you can just run and jump
around while you're waiting for your
next dentist appointment no need to dive
in into the story if you don't have that
much time
so far we've spoken about space and land
both dangerous
surely it's better down where it's
wetter under the sea
well I guess Sebastian lied in BioShock
you play Jack the only Survivor of a
plane crash into the Atlantic ocean near
the entrance to the ruined underwater
city of rapture you'll solve puzzles and
use a literal handful of special
abilities and weapons as you try to
assist a man named Atlas in stopping the
city's Creator and Ryan the game is
packed with Eerie sounds unsettling
music blood and creepy little girls with
glowing eyes Bioshock is considered
playable by Valve and in my own test I
found it to work exceptionally well the
game looks and feels right at home on
the deck's handheld form factor and is a
blast to play on the go just don't take
your quest for immersion too far I don't
think the steam deck does well submerged
in water
remember that one time at camp where you
fell in love but you also almost died me
too good times good times the Quarry
tells the story of a group of teenage
counselors hosting a party after the
final days of summer camp unfortunately
for them things aren't going to go as
planned the good news is that you play a
hand in how things turn out like until
dawn you will make choices to determine
what happens to each of the nine cam
counselors all of which are not safe
from the hands of the Grim Reaper the
Quarry is the only game on the list that
Sports a mysterious unknown label from
valve but I'm here to tell you that the
game worked just fine in my test the
frame rate was a bit all over the place
at first but when limited to 30 frames
per second in the game's menu I saw a
decent Improvement the game's overall
movie watching style of gameplay makes
it a great experience on the go just try
not to freak out and scream while you're
playing this on public transit or
something
in Alien Isolation you play as Ellen
Ripley's daughter Amanda as she seeks
information about her mother's fate when
you're doing this all while trying not
to be ripped apart by vicious Xenomorphs
the game serves as a prequel to The
Original film and it moves away from the
shooting focused action horror nature of
previous games in the alien franchise
instead isolation focuses on dread
anxiety and fearing the lone alien
creature that stalks the halls of the
space station alien isolation is listed
as verified on Steam and during our own
testing John Lew came to the conclusion
that it runs great so if Dead Space
isn't enough for you and you need to
experience more space scares while
running errands alien isolation is
perfect for you
let's be honest there are a lot of
Resident Evil games out there and at
this point in the series they could have
a steam deck video all to themselves so
for this list we're just going to focus
on the latest release Resident Evil
Village the game picks up after the
story of Resident Evil 7 and continues
to focus on Ethan Winters after rescuing
his wife Mia from the baker house
spoilers and subsequently getting saved
by Resident Evil franchise Mainstay
Chris Redfield extra spoilers the couple
tried to restart their lives in Europe
one thing leads to another and you AKA
Ethan find yourself drowning in another
crazy trauma-inducing situation valve
has Village listed as playable and that
couldn't be closer to the truth in my
experience with the game on Deck I found
Village to be extremely playable this is
also the perfect time to dive into
Village considering the winter expansion
of the game releases on October 28th
2022.
The Evil Within Stars Sebastian
Castellanos a detective called in to
investigate a vicious collection of
murders at a local mental hospital I
definitely would have called that work
that day as Sean McGinnis wrote in our
review the game doesn't rely on cheap
jump scares quote it's driven by a slow
sustained and deeply pervasive sense of
dread that sets your mind racing at
every crunch of glass beneath your feet
and every distant grown from an unseen
enemy end quote the game has a sequel
that picks up several years later after
the first game where Sebastian is now a
former detective haunted by his last
visit into a nightmare version of
reality both The Evil Within games are
listed as verified on Steam and when I
tested the first game I didn't run into
any issues so I'd say you're good to go
the little nightmares games can be best
described as a 2.5 D side scroller with
unsettling visuals in the first game you
play S6 a nine-year-old girl trapped in
the mall an underwater Resort filled
with monstrous disfigured inhabitants
that Tower over her your goal is freedom
but those deformed creatures are
conveniently in your path part 2 sees
you playing as a new character mono
while six returns in the form of your AI
companion the goal once again is freedom
and escape from a dark scary world both
games are listed as verified by Valve
and our own test concluded that they run
flawlessly in fact I feel like these
games and their side scrolling gameplay
are perfect for the deck's handheld form
factor now hit the comment section let
us know some of your favorite scary
games that you love to play on Steam
deck or which ones you plan on trying
when you get a steam deck of your own if
you don't have one already thanks for
watching we've been trying your YouTube
about your car's extended warranty
laughs